this j just just you know it's got to
stop honestly the hot dog eating
competitions
stop
it's so disgusting always
they look so gross and they're so
red-faced
and they're you know what they're doing
when they're doing it dying
they look like they're dying and then
somebody tried to protest out there they
tried to hold the sign out and protest
something that nobody even read and then
that [ __ ] joey chestnut dude just
choked them out
like
how hilarious that
you you didn't even compete
in the competition of hot dog eating and
you're the one that choked
you were just holding the sign and joey
chestnut by the way
worst name dude
is he in a boy band dude joey chestnut
is that hey joey chestnut p.i need any
certainty my services i'll get to the
bottom of it joey chestnut that's not
his real name right it can't be if it's
not his real name why didn't he just
name himself joey hot dog
yeah i'm gonna eat so many hot dogs be
the ultimate winner and then also my
last name is [ __ ] a different food is
that even a food chestnuts roasting on
an open fire
eating so many hot dogs at once
eat like 60 hot dogs my only competition
is kibiashi
oh joey chestnut
what's the guy's name kobayashi my only
competition is
that guy kobayashi or song of all time
joey chestnut's choking out protesters
never choking myself
i eat hot dogs so clean it's like i'm
sucking the dicks
i'm basically sucking dicks
this is loki homosexual
it's actually
high-key homosexual
because i'm eating
phallic things in the shape of dicks
also i changed my lame to
two words that technically are
homosexual if you think about it because
the only thing that's more homosexual
than the word nut is
chest
couple them together chestnuts the
gayest thing ever
[Laughter]
i'm so dizzy for my nose surgery yeah
yes dude
he can't hold a note without passing out
but he does it for you because he
is
a ceo
oh
dude oh my nose [ __ ] hurts
how many black dudes outside of
buildings that don't go in the buildings
hand people cards and say that they're
ceos of something yes doing your nails
[Laughter]
oh
holy [ __ ] dude
that's blacker than the cheeky for real
dude
oh [ __ ] oh i'm so dizzy dude
oh my god dude
so many [ __ ] black dudes stand
outside of buildings and don't go into
buildings and hand people cards that
come out of the buildings and say you
know i'm a ceo oh
dude
it's unreal dude
joey chestnuts roasting on an open fire
it's so gay i put things the size of
dicks in my face over and over again
the only word gayer than nut is chess
put them together that's the gay singing
of the world
nut on my chest
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] man
oh [ __ ]
i wish these hot dogs squirted come out
of them
anyway dude
is that like a picture of joey chestnut
he's looking is it so gross
[Laughter]
did he drink water
in the middle of that oh god that's so
gross bro
he looks so british too he looks like
he'd be in [ __ ] what's it called uh
that was that movie with train spotting
oh you got all dogs we gotta go in we
got a dro that's a [ __ ] new that's
how how much does [ __ ] joy chestnut
look like being a guy richie movie where
they're trying to rob a bunch of hot
dogs we're gonna go in we gotta get all
the dogs we gotta go in we gotta get all
the beef franks
collect them all in these [ __ ] buns
eat them before we leave there's a
number of hot dogs and we're gonna run
out
uh anyway he's a champ dude
so
disrespectful to july 4th to have that
[ __ ] competition on july 4th dude so
disrespectful so american but so
disrespectful nothing is more american
than having a hot dog eating competition
uh
to take over the independence day
holiday
the only
american than that is being that
disrespectful and they did it so that's
great
so i laughed too hard i sang too hard
and i hurt and it hurt my nose and it's
all good and i feel faint but it's all
good
[Music]
crazy
[Music]